but first good evening and welcome to
tucker carlson tonight
for a guy who's been in politics all of
his life joe biden has never learned to
lie very well
you'd think he would have picked up some
flair over the years given the extensive
practice he's had but no
biden still tells whoppers like a child
like that insecure fat kid in your sixth
grade class who was always bragging
about how his dad was a secret agent
when actually he worked in insurance so
there was a scary gang guy called corn
pop he was gonna kill me so i beat him
with a chain
then i went to south africa to free
nelson mandela from jail but a bunch of
nazis arrested me at the airport but i
fought him off and then
okay joe you say to yourself you're kind
of embarrassed for the guy it's just so
transparent and dumb
but biden isn't embarrassed he assumes
you believe him or maybe he's so deep in
his internal fantasy world he doesn't
care what you think
either way he keeps going tall tale
after tall tale and then i went to a
segregated black college top of my class
the guys there loved me
the whole thing is weird it's a little
sad what's interesting though
are those moments in which joe biden
doesn't lie when instead he decides to
tell the truth
in the face of criticism that's not an
easy thing to do for a man who's
desperate to be loved
so you've got to ask yourself why is he
doing it it's happening right now it's
interesting
repeatedly biden has been asked in
recent weeks whether he plans to pack
the supreme court with partisan
democrats if he's elected
the answer is obvious of course i would
never do that i'm not a radical
i'm moderate i'm from scranton you can
trust me
and in fact that's essentially the
answer biden has given on a bunch of
different issues like a fracking ban or
the green new deal
he used to support those things now he
claims he doesn't support them it's an
election year he wants to win he'll say
anything but again what's weird is that
biden
isn't trying to reassure you that he
won't pack the supreme court
most americans don't want him to do that
they don't want to destroy an entire
branch of government
turn into a political judiciary they
know that's a bad idea
but again biden is refusing to reassure
them
what does that tell you it tells you
that packing the supreme court is the
one thing joe biden is certain to do
if he's elected listen to his answer on
the question from
yesterday notice he doesn't even bother
with a colorful story
here it is i'll know my opinion of court
packing when the election is over now
look
i know it's a great question you all and
i don't blame you for asking
but you know the moment i answered that
question
the headline in every one of your papers
will be about that
we showed that clip to you last night we
just showed it to you again because we
wanted to make sure it was real we
weren't imagining it it's that
strange biden's official articulated
planned out scripted position
is that voters are not entitled to know
what he will do to their government if
they elect him
which if you think about it is itself a
pretty clear answer to the question it's
not like
he's never thought about the subject of
packing the court joe biden sat on the
senate judiciary committee for decades
famously at one point the specific issue
came up
during a hearing here's what biden said
about it
president roosevelt clearly had the
right to send to the united states
senate the united states congress a
proposal to pack the court
it was totally within his right to do
that he violated no law
he was legalistically absolutely correct
but it was a bonehead idea it was a
terrible terrible mistake to make and it
put in question
for an entire decade the independence of
the most significant body including the
congress in my view the most significant
body
in this country the supreme court of the
united states of america it was
legalistically correct even then
biden was inarticulate but he did say
very clearly court packing is a quote
terrible terrible mistake
it would ruin the integrity of the
judicial branch
that's not a profound insight in fact
it's the consensus view of historians
and judges and has been
for decades once again polls show
americans agree they oppose court
packing it's not a partisan issue
it's common sense the system has worked
this way for hundreds of years let's not
wreck it now
ruth bader ginsburg of all people had
the same view and she said so
just last year i
have heard that there are some people on
the democratic side
who would like to increase the number of
judges
i think that was a bad idea when
president franklin delano roosevelt
tried to pack the court if anything
would make the court appear
partisan it would be that one side
saying
when we're in power we're going to
enlarge the number
oh so that's one of ruth bader
ginsburg's final wishes that we're
ignoring apparently but it's pretty
inconvenient nevertheless so how is the
biden campaign explaining this away
well they put some thought into the
question just before the last vice
presidential debate
the biden campaign apparently got an
intern to google up some facts to
justify
court packing they came up with abraham
lincoln probably a few minutes before
kamala harris took the stage they handed
her the notes and she repeated it here's
what she said
abraham lincoln was up for re-election
and it was 27 days before the election
and a seat became open on the united
states supreme court
abraham lincoln's party was in charge
not only of the white house but the
senate
but honest abe said
it's not the right thing to do the
american people
deserve to make the decision about who
will be the next president of the united
states
and then that person can select who will
serve for a lifetime
on the highest court of our land
so that's kamala harris's version of
american history it's not correct
not surprisingly she really mentions it
but harris actually didn't grow up in
this country
she moved to quebec when she was 12 and
she didn't come back until after high
school
so if the question is what's the capital
of canada for the record it's a place
called
atawa kamala harris could probably tell
you
but when it comes to abraham lincoln
she's completely at sea
none of what she said was true michael
burlingame would know he runs the
lincoln studies department at the
university of
illinois at springfield and he was
baffled by what he saw at the vp debate
i've never seen anything like that quote
in all my 36 years of lincoln research
burlingame later said
in fact lincoln didn't immediately
nominate a new supreme court justice
before the 1864 election
because he couldn't the senate was not
in session at the time
and in 1864 there were fewer direct
flights to washington senators couldn't
just
hop on a red eye from california to come
in and vote things moved more slowly
in december the day after the senate
reconvened
president lincoln immediately nominated
a replacement to the court
so kamala harris's version isn't real it
didn't happen
it was her version of the corn pop story
it was colorful but entirely made up
what's not a fantasy is their plan it's
hard to believe but this is real their
plan to completely change
our american form of government that is
very close to happening
closer than a lot of republicans want to
admit and you should be worried about it